على غواصة هجومية مسيرة ذات
قدرات نووية في احدث رد على
والانتقال السياسي. الولايات
المتحدة تسقط خططها من بين
مقتل جنديتين اسرائيليتين تفاعلا
واسعا في الوسط العربي. اذ جاءت
المدنيين بعد الهجوم الذي استهدف
مطار السليماني. فلتعطني خدك كي
هذه المناقشات تركز على اعادة
فتح الموانئ والمطارات اليمنية
وطالبت بغداد انقرة بتقديم
اعتذار رسمي والتخلي عن ترويع
تقترب من الجزيرة بشكل كبير
وواضح. فهل يفعلها التنين
اعلنت البحرية الامريكية انها
ارسلت الى الشرق الاوسط الغواصة
المسجد الاقصى والمعتكفين. من
جهته اعترف قائد في الاسرائيلي
الى اتفاق دائم لوقف اطلاق النار
مع الحوثيين وذلك قبل عيد الفطر.
بالكامل ودفع رواتب موظفي القطاع
العام وعملية اعادة الاعمار
عملية غور الاردن ردا على
الاعتداءات الاسرائيلية على
اعطيك كفا وبعدها ساعتذر لك. الا
تستحون يا هؤلاء? والى اليمن حيث
الصيني? الاحداث والتطورات. اجرت
كوريا الشمالية اختبارا جديدا
المناورة الامريكية الكورية
الجنوبية. الغواصة النووية اجرت
وسبعين طائرة وتسع سفن تابعة
لجيش التحرير الشعبي الصيني
البحرين مقرا له. كون الادارة
الامريكية تلقت معلومات تفيد بان
بينها حالات خطيرة. هناك اصدر
نتنياهو تعليمات للشرطة
بصواريخ موجهة وذلك دعما للاسطول
الخامس الامريكي الذي يتخذ من
الاسرائيلية بتعبئة جميع وحدات
شرطة الحدود الاحتياطية وامر
وكالة الانباء الكورية الشمالية.
شهدت عملية الاغوار التي خلفت
يو اس اس فلوريدا التي تعمل
بالطاقة النووية والمزودة
ايران تخطط لتنفيذ هجمات المنطقة
قريبا وفق صحيفة دان العراق ما
والاعلام والتطويق الكامل
لتايوان. حيث تاتي هذه المناورات
تنتهي العمليات هنا لننتقل الى
قلب تل ابيب هذه المرة. وذلك بعد
بفشل قواته في ردع العملية التي
فر منفذوها من مكان الحادث. لم
الواقعية عقب عودة رئيسة تايوان
من زيارة للولايات المتحدة والتي
المزاح قد انتهى. وها هي وزارة
الدفاع التايوانية تعلن رصد احدى
ان تعرض الاسرائيليون لعمليتي
دهس واطلاق نار خلفت عدة اصابات
الاسرائيلي بتعبئة قوات اضافية.
فهل هي نار الانتقام العربية
ايديها ليستلقفها الدب الروسي.
فهل تعلن موسكو النهاية بهذه
محاكاة تحت المياه قطعت خلالها
مسافة الف كيلو متر وذلك بحسب
التعامل بها قبل اي حرب كما فعلت
روسيا قبل غزو اوكرانيا لتركز
وصل مبعوثون وعمانيون الى
العاصمة اليمنية صنعاء للتوصل
وصفها بالاعتداءات السافرة
لتركيا على اراضيه وسيادته.
تذليل العقبات امام الصادرات
الروسية من الحبوب والاسمدة
ولا لاوكرانيا بل ولا للعالم
باسره بديلا عن استعادة شبه
الكلام وحان وقت العمل. التنين
الصيني يكشر عن انيابه تجاه
لقد ظهر الى جوار الجنود
المسلمين. وبعد ان احرق الجنود
لطالما حذر الصينيون منها. نعم.
اصحاب العيون الضيقة يعلنون وقت
وهنا يؤكد الرئيس الاوكراني على
شرطه للسلام. قائلا بانه ليس له
عن طريق البر او الانهار. الصين
تبدأ باجراءات الغزو. انتهى وقت
التدريبات العسكرية لمدة ثلاثة
ايام في مضيق هذه المناورات يتم
تلك التدريبات على هدف السيطرة
على البحر والمجال الجوي
نووية لدولة ما على اراضي دولة
اخرى في اشارة للاسلحة الروسية
لوح الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير
بوتين بالعمل خارج نطاق اتفاق
لهدفه اولا برأيكم ومن المعارك
الكلامية الى حرب الغذاء. حيث
باستعادة شبه جزيرة القرم وانهاء
ما وصفه بالاحتلال الروسي لها.
وكما يقولها المثل اليمني? حقكم
حق وحق الناس مرق. ليأتي على
الاوكران كتاب المسلمين المقدس
القرآن الكريم. وكأن الزينسكي
محذرا الدول الغربية من ان
اوكرانيا قد تضطر لتصدير الحبوب
الجزيرة. هنا تؤكد الصين نفاذ
صبري تجاه جزيرة وتنفذ تدريبات
بقوله منذ فترة طويلة لم نسمع
مثل هذه الانتقادات الشديدة من
ميدفيديف ليرد على زلينستي قائلا
ان اوكرانيا ستزول من فمن يصل
في بلا روسيا ليرد عليه المتحدث
الروسي ديمتري بسكوف بشكل ساخر
الرئيس الاوكراني الذي عاود
الظهور مجددا. ولكن اين? نعم.
لماكرون ضرورة توفير الظروف
الواقعية لتسوية ازمة اوكرانيا
حيث اجتمع الرئيس الصيني بنظيره
الفرنسي. هناك اكد شي جين بينغ
تايمز. ومن الحروب الدائرة الى
اصحاب العيون الضيقة ونقصد بكين
تصدير الحبوب الاوكرانية عبر
موانئ البحر الاسود اذا لم يتم
الاوروبيين لمنح اوكرانيا خارطة
طريق لعضوية حلف الناتو وذلك
شبه واقعية على الية غزو حيث
اعلن الجيش الصيني بدأ تلك
عدد من الضباط والجنود المسلمين
في الجيش الاوكراني. متعهدا
شهر رمضان المقدس للمسلمين ليقيم
مأدبة افطار لهم ويقوم بتكريم
جزيرة القرم. هناك انبرى نائب
رئيس مجلس الامن الروسي ديمتري
سياسيا. لكن ماكرون اتجه نحو
الحديث عن عدم جواز وضع اسلحة
الاوكرانية. حيث ان الولايات
المتحدة تقاوم جهود بعض الحلفاء
بقمة الحلف المقررة في يوليو
المقبل وفق صحيفة فاينانشيال
كشفها يجيب المسئولون الامريكيون
انه من المرجح ان تكون روسيا او
فخا في الامر. وهنا تتواصل
الضربات الامريكية لحليفتها
الاستخباراتي وان المعلومات فقد
وقعت بيد الدب الروسي ليعلن
عناصر جاسوسية موالية لها وراء
تلك التسريبات وفق رويترز فيا له
وتحقق في الامر الذي قد يدخل
الولايات المتحدة في ازمة كبيرة
في صد الغزو الروسي وملفات خاصة
بالشرق الاوسط والصين لتشكل هذه
التسريبات كابوسا عظيما ليس
للولايات المتحدة فقط بل
لاوكرانيا ونقاط الضعف المحتملة
وجهود الناتو الواسعة للمساعدة
الرئيس الفرنسي تجاه الولايات
المتحدة. اي ان امريكا تضع
اسراره العسكرية لتتدخل هذه
المرة وزارة العدل الامريكية
تتعلق بالامن القومي الامريكي
وتوضح بالتفصيل القدرات القتالية
من سقوط مدون. فان ذهبت افلام
جيمس بوند من هذا الفشل
العالم. انه البنتاجون الامريكي
وبعد ان فشل في الحفاظ على
الاستخباراتية. فيا لها من ضربة
في مقتل للغربيين. فمن ذا الذي
كانت في غنى وبحسب نيويورك تايمز
فانه تم تسريب مائة وثيقة سرية
اسلحتها في العديد من الدول
فلماذا لم تتكلم عندها يا ماكرون
تصيب واشنطن في مقتل. لسانك
حصانك ان صنته صانك. هكذا يقولها
اصبحت كتابا مفتوحا امام عدوك.
وقد يعني ذلك خسارة مسبقة للحرب
يقدم الاعتذار. لكن هل انتظرت كل
هذا الوقت يا هذا? زينسكي استغل
يتجه لايقاف اتفاق الحبوب فهل
تعود حرب البطون الخاوية?
الاردن تشتبك عسكريا مع اسرائيل
لتعلن بعدها حالة الطوارئ. موسكو
العرب. وفي الحرب ستكون معلوماتك
وخططك العسكرية هي ذلك الحصان.
والتوقف عن ترويع الامنين.
وواشنطن تتحضر نووي للرد على
هو ان طالت قليلا. نعم. وها نحن
امام اهم واقوى مؤسسة عسكرية في
ايران. والانتقام الفلسطيني
يشتعل من قلب تل ابيب. ونتنياهو
يأمر بتعبئة جديدة واليمن في
طريقه الى السلام الدائم. بينما
وفي حال سقطت تلك الخطط العسكرية
في الحروب بيد العدو فذلك انك
حينها انتصاره بهذه الحرب. فهل
هي معلومات صحيحة? ام ان هناك
لبريطانيا ونيوزيلندا وكندا ايضا
اللواتي يتبادلن المعلومات
المتحدة الامريكية تكتم انفاسها
والعراق لتركيا. عليكم الاعتذار
التسريبات
عاصفة تسرب الوثائق الامريكية.
ها هم اليوم يكشفون عن الفاعل.
والمجنون يجري اختبارا نووي تحت
الماء هذه المرة. والولايات
طلب الدول الاوروبية بضم
اوكرانيا للناتو. فيما بوتين
والزينونسكي يضع شرطا للسلام
ويعتذر للمسلمين. وامريكا ترفض
وبكين تؤكد نفاد صبرها لتعلن عن
اول اجراءات غزو تايوان. وبعد
حذرناكم ولم تسمعوا وهذا ما جنته
ايديكم. غضب صيني من تايوان